House of the Dragon is a Game
of Thrones prequel show that is
confirmed by HBO’s president to air in 2022.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve as
showrunners and executive producers. George R.
R. Martin will also serve as executive producer.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book
Fire And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet
unfinished Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold that
iconic seat, all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
That's Fire And Blood volume 1.
The yet unreleased Fire And Blood volume
2 will continue from where part 1 ended,
with Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's
reign and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war
with Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
The key event of the show is also the
key in the history of House Targaryen,
the Dance of the Dragons - the Targaryen civil
war, which divided the entire kingdom and launched
a huge war that was fought from 129 AC to 131 AC.
The Dance of the Dragons was the most devastating
war in the history of the Seven Kingdoms.
A war of succession between Aegon II
and his half-sister Rhaenyra over
their father Viserys I's throne.
Both of them thought they belonged on the
Iron Throne. When people started declaring
for one of them or the other, their
fight divided the kingdoms in two.
Targaryens fought Targaryens, bothers
fought brothers, dragons fought dragons.
By the time it was over, thousands were dead.
One of the key characters in the
Targaryen civil war is Queen Alicent.
Alicent Hightower was a member of House Hightower
who became the second wife
to King Viserys I Targaryen
and therefore a Queen of the Targaryen dynasty.
She was the daughter of Ser Otto Hightower,
who had been the Hand of the King to Jaehaerys
I, Viserys I, and later his grandson Aegon II.
She was the mother of King Aegon II, Queen
Helaena, Prince Aemond and Prince Daeron.
Alicent Hightower was in many ways
the true leader of Aegon II's faction
during the Dance of the Dragons.
Alicent's father Otto Hightower had been Hand of
the King in the last few years of the long reign
of King Jaehaerys I Targaryen. In 101 AC Otto
brought the young Alicent to the royal court,
where she cared for the aging king.
Jaehaerys eventually died in 103 AC,
while Alicent was reading to him and was
succeeded by his grandson Viserys I.
Alicent stayed at court, as her father
continued to occupy the position as the Hand
under Jaehaerys's grandson and successor,
King Viserys I Targaryen.
Already early in the reign of Viserys, Ser Otto
and Prince Daemon Targaryen were at odds with each
other, and the court fool Mushroom has suggested
that the quarrel between the two men began
when Daemon deflowered Alicent. The truths of
these tales have never been uncovered.
Viserys I's first queen, Aemma Arryn,
only produced one living child
before her death - a daughter,
Rhaenyra. In the years that followed, Alicent
caught the eye of King Viserys I Targaryen,
and Viserys chose Alicent as his
second wife. They married in 106 AC,
despite the whispers of people who believed
that the Hand had risen above himself.
Some doubted Alicent's virtue as rumors began
circling that she had given her maidenhead
to Prince Daemon and had later even slept with
King Viserys while Queen Aemma was still alive.
The notorious Mushroom suggested that Alicent had
been intimate with the late Jaehaerys as well.
Nonetheless, Alicent was wed to Viserys. At
first young Rhaenyra and Alicent got along well,
but a rift grew between them as soon as Alicent
produced her own children for Viserys I,
and clearly wanted them to succeed
to the throne instead of her.
Alicent bore Viserys I four
children: Aegon II, Aemond One-Eye,
Daeron the Daring and Helaena (who
became the sister-wife of Aegon II).
Over the years of Viserys I's reign, despite
his best efforts, a bitter rivalry grew
between Alicent and Rhaenyra at court as well as
between their rival factions of supporters.
In 111 AC, a great tourney
was held at King's Landing
on the fifth anniversary of the King’s marriage
to Queen Alicent. At the opening feast,
Alicent wore a green gown while Princess
Rhaenyra dressed in Targaryen red and black.
Soon afterward, their respective followers started
dressing in similar colors and styles to display
their political allegiance: Rhaenyra's faction
(the "Princess's followers") wore black clothing
and Alicent's faction ("the Queen's
followers") wore green clothing.
Ultimately this inspired the nicknames for the
two factions: "the Blacks and the Greens".
The Blacks (Rhaenyra's supporters) included
the Starks, Tullys, Arryns, Tarlys,
and Velaryons (among others), while the Greens
(Alicent's supporters) included the Hightowers
and the Lannisters, among others. The Baratheons
started out as Blacks, but switched to the Greens
when the civil war began, while the Tyrells
may have been Greens at first, but during the
civil war itself declared themselves neutral.
When Rhaenyra turned sixteen, the small council
started looking for a suitable husband.
Alicent had her own choice: her eldest son,
Prince Aegon, who, while the princess was sixteen
years old, was only six years old himself. Viserys
argued that the siblings had never gotten along,
but Alicent urged her husband that was all
the more reason to wed the two.
Viserys refused, believing that
Alicent only made the suggestion to
get her own blood on the throne.
Alicent's eldest son Aegon grew to be a lazy man,
prone to indulging his lusts with mistresses
as well as prone to outbursts of anger. Given
that Aegon II had no great political skill,
it was his mother Alicent who was seen
as the true leader of his faction
however he was not necessarily an outright
puppet, as they shared the same goals.
Alicent is the real political
mastermind behind her son.
The Dance of the Dragons was seen so much
as a rivalry between Princess Rhaenyra and
Queen Alicent that George R.R. Martin's
prequel novella about the conflict was
titled "The Princess and the Queen", referring
to the two of them instead of to Aegon II.
Viserys I publicly and repeatedly made
the great lords of the realm swear oaths
that Rhaenyra would succeed him on the
Iron Throne as the first Ruling Queen.
A matter of hours after Viserys I died in
his sleep, however, Alicent staged a coup –
one that she had been long
planning to the fine details.
One night, a servant found the old king had died
in his sleep and ran to inform Queen Alicent.
Protocol dictated that the bells would
be rung, everyone notified and a raven
sent to Dragonstone to summon the heir,
Princess Rhaenyra, for her coronation.
But Alicent had other plans.
Once she saw her dead husband's body,
she sealed the room and had the servant thrown
into the Black Cells to ensure his silence.
According to Mushroom, who was away
with Rhaenyra Targaryen on Dragonstone,
Alicent poisoned Viserys's drink. True
or not, instead of announcing Viserys I's
death immediately, Alicent warned Ser Criston
Cole, now Lord Commander of the Kingsguard,
and together they called the small
council to discuss the succession,
where plans were made to crown
Alicent's son Prince Aegon,
instead of Princess Rhaenyra,
who had been Viserys's heir.
Of the seven-man council
(including her father Otto),
all were Greens except for old
Master of Coin Lyman Beesbury.
Alicent soon made it clear that
she intended to crown Aegon II,
against her late husband's wishes.
The debate did not end till dawn when
the Master of Coin declared this to be treason.
In response, Lord Commander of the Kingsguard
Criston Cole silently snuck
behind Beesbury's chair,
and without a word slashed his throat. As
the old man bled out onto the council table,
the remaining council members seated
around it (including Alicent) continued
to plan out the next steps in their coup.
Her son rejected the Iron Throne at first, but
was told by Alicent that Rhaenyra would kill him
and his siblings if she was to become a Queen.
The coronation ceremony was soon after held
for Aegon II and Helaena, Aegon's sister-wife,
in the Dragonpit while Rhaenyra
was crowned at Dragonstone.
This rivalry exploded into
massive civil war between
their two rival factions of House Targaryen,
a conflict known as the Dance of the Dragons.
After the coronation, Alicent moved her chambers
to the Tower of the Hand, where her father
resided. Every evening before bed, Queen Helaena
brought her children to see their grandmother.
Because the Tower of the Hand was
less secure than Maegor's Holdfast,
Blood and Cheese hired by Daemon were
able to take advantage of this custom.
They sneaked into Alicent's chambers, slew
her bedmaid, and bound and gagged Alicent.
When Helaena arrived with the children, they slew
Prince Jaehaerys, Aegon's eldest son and heir,
as revenge for the death
of Rhaenyra's son Lucerys.
Helaena subsequently went mad with grief.
Aegon gave his surviving son, Prince Maelor,
to his mother Alicent to raise.
Later in the war, Aemond Targaryen foolishly
led the Green army defending King's Landing north
to strike against Harrenhal, leaving the capital
with only a skeleton defense.
Rhaenyra's forces were then able
to take King's Landing in a surprise assault,
with Rhaenyra herself leading from dragon-back.
The City Watch supported Rhaenyra as they were
loyal to Daemon and threw the gates open to
her army, and also killed a few Green officers
that Aegon II had installed to command them,
including Alicent's own brother Gwayne. Aegon
II was sneaked out of the city in secret.
Several members of the Green Council, however,
were captured and executed as traitors - among
them Alicent's father Otto. Alicent was also
captured, and Rhaenyra came to meet her.
Despite the bitter rivalry between the two,
Rhaenyra announced that for the memory of
the love of her father, she would spare Alicent's
life. During the exchange between the two queens,
Alicent made references to an old
rumor stating that Rhaenyra's first
three sons were not legitimate Targaryens,
but the bastards from Ser Harwin Strong.
According to Septon Eustace and Grand Maester
Munkun, Rhaenyra, furious at this accusation,
threatens Alicent to have her tongue removed
if she continued to spread this lie again.
According to Mushroom, Rhaenyra's mistress of
whisperers and Daemon's former lover, Mysaria,
dissuaded her from taking Alicent's tongue and
instead suggested another terrible punishment,
but also more poetic: Alicent and her
daughter should be sent to the Street of Silk
to work as ladies of night. Mysaria
reportedly told Rhaenyra: ''Let them
remain there until they are with child.
They speak of bastards so freely,
let them each have one of their own.''
Moreover, Mushroom cited this event as the cause
of Alicent's daughter's decision to end it all
as she probably got pregnant. Rhaenyra remained
in control of the capital for about half a year,
but through several surprising turns of events
Rhaenyra had to withdraw from the city and
the Greens recaptured it. As the armies of
the Lads and Lord Cregan Stark advanced on the
capital, plotters plotted against Aegon II.
The king was found poisoned and
Alicent was arrested by Velaryons.
Aegon II had captured and fed Rhaenyra
to his dragon before his own death.
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son took the throne
as Aegon III Targaryen in 131 AC. During
the Hour of the Wolf, Lord Cregan Stark punished
all men who betrayed King Aegon II and Alicent.
While Cregan was Rhaenyra's supporter and had
believed that Aegon II had been a usurper
and had been riding south to oust him from power,
Lord Stark did not believe in killing him,
but rather in defeating him
on the field of battle.
Alicent survived through the end of the
war, but at great cost: all four of her
children and grandchildren had died. Therefore
Alicent lived to see her own bloodline end.
Alicent remained in her chambers for the
last year of her life. Alicent often wept,
began talking to herself, and came to
dislike the color green. She died in 133 AC,
during the outbreak of Winter Fever.
Twenty major battles on land, in the
sky and on the sea, even more smaller battles,
and even more betrayals, turncloaks, and twists,
all of that and more this Game of Thrones prequel
show, House of the Dragon, brings in 2022.
Let me know your thoughts about all of
this in the comment section down below.
Thank you so much for watching and
I hope to see you in the next one.
Peace!